cada barrio de Bagdad ha quedado marcado
por las diferentes guerras que han
devastado el país desde la invasión
estadounidense en 2003
en esta casa de zather City vive la
familia del mustafa lazari que fue
linchado y ahorcado por el estado
islámico
después de que daish avanzó por el país
y el ayatolá proclamó una fatua para
unirse a su defensa mustafa pidió
permiso a mis padres para luchar contra
los asesinos
las imágenes de su hermano siendo
exhibido en la ciudad de faluya antes de
ser ejecutado revivieron en esta familia
el dolor de la guerra sectaria que
desangró Irak entre 2006 y 2008
algunos hombres levantan la mano en
señal de aprobación y su hermano en el
medio como un trofeo
sentimos mucha tristeza porque mustafa
fue a esta región a defenderlos si bien
es zonas unita es tierra iraquí su
responsabilidad es defenderla
el asesinato de mustafa destruyó a esta
familia su padre murió meses después y
su madre apenas puede ponerse de pie
después de la invasión nos sentimos bien
Por poco tiempo luego Todo fue un caos
empezaron a matarse unos a otros
imán Recuerda que durante años los
unitas y chitas se mataron entre ellos
cuenta que en esta calle de este barrio
sunita aparecía muertos todos los días
la familia de sugerir fue una de las
tantas que tuvo que buscar refugio en
este barrio sunita después del asesinato
de su esposo en 2006 la guerra sectaria
desplazó a cientos de miles de personas
dentro de la ciudad en busca de la
protección de los suyos
vivíamos en la lucha una zona de mayoría
chichita nos mandaban amenazas pero mi
esposo se rehusó a irse Porque habíamos
comprado la casa nos mandaron avisos más
de una vez hasta que se lo llevaron de
su almacén
miles de mujeres han quedado viudas en
estos años de guerra Ha logrado educar a
sus hijos gracias a organizaciones como
las que dirige imán teive la mayor
recibirá el título de abogada en pocos
meses pero le preocupan especial el
futuro de sus dos hijos varones en un
país cada vez más empobrecido